you design bikes what else uh what else
do you do is that your is that your
profession that is that's my main
profession for the last 20 years or so
and it's not just the frames or the
bikes I'd also do Graphics or smaller
parts like wheels or handlebars
wheels are not a smaller apartment oh
and those little Fringe Parts like
Wheels you know some people some people
get crazy and want Wheels when I get an
assignment it's either the frame that I
have to design or the graphics or the
wheels or the handlebars it's all just a
matter of putting all those components
together but the client is usually
um somebody who makes either the frame
or The Handlebar or the wheels got it
like that now what do you have another
profession as well or is it exclusively
bikes well on the side I also have a
small company that designs horse riding
underwear what just twice straight that
was gonna be my guess from cycling my
bet my guess was gonna be either you
sell heroin or you make horse riding
underwear wait a minute is there special
underwear for people that ride horses
yeah well there's now they're used there
wasn't until I started well you can
imagine there's quite a lot of vibration
in the saddle yes when they're moving
around in certain writing styles yes
yeah hey could you keep rocking up and
down like that yeah
Grenade just do that again all right
let's play a little music
from the sides not the music you are on
completely different pages you're here
you're riding a horse and I'm in late
70s full-on steel parts I gotta say I
don't ride horse so excuse me for not
portraying it correctly did you make
these so that you could also use them
for the bicycle is that part of it or
did I just give you a brilliant idea
well if if you sit more upright than our
padding would be uh correct then it
would be very nice but the position of
the the God is different for horse
riding and for cycling so the cycling
wear would not be suitable for horse
riding which is why I came up with the
specifically for the horse ride Renee
let's get into specifics here you're
riding a horse what are we and you talk
about abrasion are we are we protecting
um let me just be very clear and
clinical the genitalia or the ass region
or the area in between which I think
science calls the tank what are we
protecting uh we're protecting
everything so it's sort of like a
diamond shape yeah I would imagine that
perineum you got the pubic arches where
you're sitting on yeah over five billion
pubic area by the way my pubic Arch
collapsed a while ago and now I'm
wearing pubic Orthotics
oh God it was a pubic Gulch yeah
so uh so so Renee no you know you need
to apologize to everybody in this I just
rolled up a piece of paper and fire it
at you with my fingers Governor Brian
needs a friend is brought to you by
T-Mobile from listening to your favorite
podcast while driving cross country to
listening at home T-Mobile helps you
stay connected I wonder what people's
favorite podcast is oh I've got some
ideas actually it's one idea yeah you'll
figure it out T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can
have seamless video calling oh that's
good streaming your favorite podcast I'm
not gonna say which one it is yeah
downloading apps games boy you know what
a gamer I am you're such a gamer play
starbursters yeah or realm of Thanos
you can watch your favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at t-mobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds going to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access details at
t-mobile.com
Renee if you don't mind me really
because I'm interested in designing my
own binding netherwear oh God this
equestrian gear why did you get into
what made you think of getting into
designing underwear for horse riders at
the time my girlfriend was a horse rider
and I was designing cycling uh wear for
uh for my clients and she saw me working
with this um this foam this pad that you
wear on this on the in the cycling
shorts yes and she said oh my God I want
this for horse riding some kind of
padding some kind of uh comfort and I
asked well don't you have this kind of
stuff here in the in the equestrian
world so I dug into that whole market
and there was
well barely anything so I started
designing uh new underwear wow so so you
do you create this company with your
girlfriend yeah which is now actually my
ex-girlfriend but the company still
exists to make things a little bit less
complicated okay I don't want it no it's
all good I don't want this to be awkward
but the business survived the breakup of
the relationship exactly yeah okay
that's very nice do you still work
together yeah yeah so it sounds like you
invented I don't have an office where we
meet each other every day but yeah we
see each other it's ironic that you
designed a garment that could cut down
on friction
but not the friction in your
relationship wow wow what do you think
of that that was profound deep yeah hey
think about this I've got a question why
not cut out the middleman and isn't it
time to reinvent the saddle it's just an
old leather thing what if you put the
foam on the saddle you know what I like
the way you're thinking and I want a
piece of this business no yeah I just
thought of it I know and I'm here to say
Me too good idea there was a guy next to
Edison who said I like it and he got 50
of the light bulb
um Renee what do you think about what
Matt just said that you're you know
let's let's fix the saddle well there
are uh foam pads that you can lay over
the saddle I don't want something I love
the riding that needs to have more
contact with the lettuce settle there's
a reason why it's so hard because you
need to be able to steer the horse with
very subtle movements with the with the
legs hmm I didn't know that but my
ex-girlfriend told me about it I think
there's a better way to I I would like
to suggest a better way to steer the
horse because traditionally I think
people use their legs and they use the
reins but I think this is something that
could be done with one of those Wii
controllers there's a way to do this
what about just a steering wheel and
plant it into the hole I tried that once
okay yeah
it's great listening to the two of you
talk about horse riding well yeah I bet
it is I feel like we're making never
ridden a horse we're making vast
improvements already between the two of
us we've reinvented the saddle which
will now be made of a very different
material probably some sort of soft meat
and uh and also uh do we need the horse
let me ask that yeah if we were just to
get a motorcycle or yes what about four
wheels okay and then you have a really
nice seat and a steering wheel a
steering wheel I'm in on this I went in
on this yeah and you call it uh so
whatever a Mustang a Mustang yeah very
go I think we've now transformed your
business radically you need to move to
Detroit let's start making things I
agree with this reasoning I'm not a big
horse fan either so I prefer four wheels
or two wheels do you think the fact that
you don't like horses and in fact just
admit it to hating them led to the break
of your relationship yeah
no it wasn't that oh okay but maybe a
little small part all right